das james webb teleskop ist an seinem
weltraum parkplatz l2 angekommen und hat
sich entfaltet die messinstrumente sind
fokussiert und geben uns einen besseren
blick ins universum als jemals zuvor
insgesamt vier bilder hat die nase am 12
juli veröffentlicht hier können wir
einen blick auf den carina nebel werfen
um mehr über die sternentstehung zu
erfahren und das hier ist ein bild des
südlichen ring nebels um den sternen tod
besser zu verstehen in dieser aufnahme
hier sieht man stevens quintett das neue
erkenntnisse darüber liefern soll wie
sich galaxien im frühen universum
gebildet haben und zu guter letzt haben
wir ein bild von max 07 23 bekommen
womit man sehr alte galaxien untersuchen
möchte außerdem gab es noch ein extra
eine spektrale aufnahme von 96 bei einem
exoplaneten um mehr über seine chemische
zusammensetzung zu lernen das james webb
funktioniert also tadellos aber jetzt
kommen wir zum eigentlichen
interessanten teil an der ganzen sache
nämlich die forschungsmissionen die das
james webb die nächsten 20 jahre lang
durchführen wird denn das webs
hauptaufgabe und diese missionen werden
jetzt gerade schon in diesem moment da
draußen im all durchgeführt und es gibt
eine menge davon lasst uns also mal
darüber sprechen welche großen fragen
der wissenschaft in nächster zeit
beantwortet werden
[Musik]
als sie gesehen haben wie unglaublich
diese ersten bilder des james webb sind
haben wir uns gedacht das muss gefeiert
wir haben und genau das machen wir jetzt
auch in dem wir das zweite mal überhaupt
doktor watson word strom und zwar dieses
mal nicht mit dem province mars rover
sondern natürlich mit dem james webb
teleskop das design hat stefan aus
unserer postproduktion entworfen und ich
finde es richtig megane als und kleiner
fun fact das ist tatsächlich offiziell
von der nasa geprüft ab heute könnt ihr
euch die shirts bestellen und natürlich
gilt wieder sie werden nachhaltig
hergestellt und alle in der
arbeitsstätte werden fair bezahlt ab
jetzt sammeln wir für circa vier wochen
lang alle bestellungen und geben erst
dann den auftrag zur produktion damit
exakt die richtige menge an t shirts
hergestellt wird und am ende nichts
weggeschmissen werden muss den link zu
bestellen findet ihr unten in der video
beschreibung okay lass uns nicht mehr
länger um den heißen brei herum reden
und über die erste mission sprechen
mit dem james webb können wir quasi in
die vergangenheit schauen denn das
teleskop kann nicht beobachten dass wir
bis zu 13 milliarden jahren imitiert
wurde genaueres dazu findet übrigens in
diesem video hier wo ich alles über das
james webb erklärt habe trotzdem hier
noch mal ganz kurz die kurzfassung bei
der cosmos web mission schaut das
teleskop auf einen 2 x 2 grad großen
bereich des universums dieser spezielle
bereich ist bereits sehr gut untersucht
und es wurden hunderte von paper aus den
ergebnissen publiziert
mit dem james webb teleskop lässt sich
diese ecke des universums jetzt aber
noch besser beobachten da es andere
wellenlängen messen kann und sensitiver
ist selbst bei niedriger lichtintensität
das ist wichtig zum beispiel wenn man
die galaxien beobachten möchte die
besonders weit entfernt sind wenn das
licht dieser galaxien muss auf seinem
weg zu uns nicht nur mit weltraum staub
klarkommen sondern verliert auf den
weiten weg auch an intensität außerdem
sind die wellenlängen roth verschoben
und diese verschiebung zu messen ist die
spezialität von james webb dafür hat es
gleich mehrere messgeräte an bord bei
der bildgebung haben wir die mir kam für
kürzere wellenlängen und miri für die
etwas längeren infrarot werden diese
erweiterung in größere wellenlängen
ermöglicht ganz neue einblicke in unser
universum
apropos rotverschiebung genau in diesem
bereich des universums wurde etwas
eigenartiges beobachtet man hat ein
lichtspektrum gefunden dessen ursache
man noch nicht zuordnen kann und nannte
die galaxie die dieses licht aussendet
cr7 und das ist kein zufall die galaxie
wurde wirklich nach cristiano ronaldo
genannt was die recherche im internet
etwas erschwert hat da man ständig nur
auf ronaldo bilder stößt aber gut für
dieses phänomen gibt es zwei mögliche
erklärungen eine könnte die bildung der
ersten sterne in unserem universum sein
die geburt dieser sterne hat 800
millionen jahre nach dem urknall
stattgefunden also vor circa 12,9
milliarden jahren um das in relation zu
setzen wenn das universum heutzutage ein
80 jähriger mensch wäre wäre es bei der
entstehung der ersten sterne das knapp
sechs jahre alt gewesen
zu dieser zeit haben sich die sterne
noch aus reinem wasserstoff geformt sein
bedeutet dass dieser wasserstoff nicht
von schwereren elementen verunreinigt
wurde die zum beispiel durch super nur
wer von sternen späterer generationen
ausgestoßen wurden und genau diese
reinheit könnte dieses ungewöhnliche
spektrum verursachen aber es gibt ja
noch möglichkeit nummer zwei das
spektrum wurde durch einen direkten
kollaps von einer gaswolke zu einem
schwarzen loch ausgesandt das ist
ungewöhnlich denn normalerweise formen
sich aus gaswolken eigentlich zuerst
sterne und die kollabieren dann erst zu
einem schwarzen loch nun brauchen wir
das james webb um den fall aufzuklären
[Musik]
habt ihr euch eigentlich schon mal
gefragt was passiert wenn das james webb
beschädigt wird und keine fotos mehr
machen kann gibt es eine
berufsunfähigkeitsversicherung für space
teleskope vermutlich nicht aber für euch
gibt es dir auf jeden fall zum beispiel
bei clark dem sponsor des heutigen
videos clark ist ein digitaler
versicherungsmanager der euch in einer
praktischen app anzeigt was ihr für eure
versicherungen zahlt und was diese
versicherungen alles für euch abdecken
wenn ihr dann über klar keine neue
versicherung abschließt dann könnt ihr
von ausgebildeten versicherungsmaklern
ganz individuelle und personalisierte
dabei beraten werden nur von space
teleskopen haben die glaube ich weniger
ahnung aber achtung die schließt damit
auch ein makler mandat ab das bedeutet
clark an versicherungen für euch
abschließen und kündigen allerdings
natürlich nur mit eurer zustimmung
falls ihr also schon einen makler hat
kann diesen auch das mandat entzogen
werden das alles könnt ihr natürlich
jederzeit widerrufen und euer konto auch
wieder schließen das ganze klingt
interessant für euch dann klickt unten
in der video beschreibung auf den ersten
link und holt euch die klage ab mit dem
kot watson kriegt ihr mit jeder
hochgeladenen versicherungen einen 50
euro einkaufsgutschein bis zu maximal 45
euro und unterstützt dabei auch noch uns
und weitere spannende videos
[Musik]
seit 1996 ist bekannt dass sich im
zentrum der milchstraße ein
supermassives schwarzes loch mit der
masse von vier millionen sonnen befindet
ein interview mit dem wissenschaftler
der dafür 2020 den nobelpreis erhalten
hat findet übrigens hier doch wie ist
das schwarze loch da hingekommen ist es
woanders entstanden oder hatte sich dort
geformt und was war eigentlich zuerst da
die planeten oder das schwarze loch und
damit sind wir schon bei der nächsten
mission die das james webb gerade
durchführt
durch das james webb teleskop haben wir
die möglichkeit viel schärfere aufnahmen
vom zentrum der milchstraße zu machen um
das zentrum herum gibt es nämlich ganz
schön viel zeug dass da einfach so herum
schwirrt staubt zum beispiel der das
licht davon abhält zu uns zu kommen was
ärgerlich ist denn dieses licht brauchen
wir ganz unbedingt um das zentrum der
milchstraße zu erforschen hinfahren um
gesteinsproben zu nehmen können wir ja
leider nicht helfen kann uns aber erneut
infrarotes licht da das nicht so leicht
absorbiert wird dadurch erhalten die
forschenden die möglichkeit durch dieses
dickicht an ganz vielen partikeln bis
zum zentrum unserer galaxie durch
zuschauen dabei kann es objekte nah am
zentrum des schwarzen lochs beobachten
und ihre bewegungen messen um dadurch
die dort herrschende gravitation zu
berechnen unter umständen könnte es um
das supermassive schwarze loch nämlich
eine ansammlung von noch weiteren
kleineren schwarzen löchern geben die um
das zentrum kreisen das wollen die
forscher und forscherinnen nun mit
dieser mission herausfinden all das
hilft uns mehr darüber zu erfahren wie
unsere galaxie entstanden ist besonders
die frage wie sich sterne so nah am
zentrum formen konnten ist spannend denn
dort herrscht große gravitation was das
ganze bisher ziemlich unerklärlich macht
wenn dabei demnächst etwas krasses
herauskommt dann erfahrt ihr das
natürlich hier bei doktor watson als
erstes
[Musik]
das trap ist ein planetensystem ist 40
lichtjahre von uns entfernt und ein ganz
heißer kandidat für eine erde 2.0 und
zwar aufgrund seiner sieben exoplaneten
diese sieben planeten haben einen sehr
kleinen orbit und das mal in relation zu
setzen alle sieben befinden sich
innerhalb der distanz von sonne und
merkur zu ihrem stern da dieser stern
aber wiederum viel kleiner und kälter
ist befinden sich nichtsdestotrotz vier
von ihnen in einer bewohnbaren zone also
nicht zu heiß und nicht zu kalt so weit
so gut nun möchte man herausfinden aus
welchen elementen die atmosphäre dieser
planeten besteht damit kann man
abschätzen ob dort leben möglich wäre
wenn das licht des sterns die atmosphäre
der planeten durchquert werden gewisse
wellenlängen absorbiert und das gesamte
spektrum des sterns verändert sich diese
spektren liegen im infrarotbereich und
das ist ja eine der leichtesten übungen
von james webb mit seinem riesigen honig
warten spiegeln kann es den lichteinfall
zusätzlich maximieren und so sogar die
schwächsten lichtsignale auslesen in
diesem lichtspektrum können wir dann
sehen welche wellenlängen absolviert
wurden und so können forscherinnen und
forscher darauf schließen welche
elemente und moleküle sich um diese
atmosphäre befinden am besten wäre es
natürlich irgendwas wie wasser co2
methan oder stickstoff zu finden weil
das ein zeichen dafür wäre dass auf
diesem planeten theoretisch leben
entstehen könnte
okay das waren jetzt drei der projekte
aber die liste ist ja noch viel viel
länger leider können wir euch in diesem
ein video hier nicht über alle 286
projekte etwas erzählen aber wir konnten
nicht widerstehen euch noch ein paar
weitere highlights aus der liste schnell
zu pitchen die gmz elf war lange die
älteste bekannte galaxie
2022 wurde sie aber von hd 1 abgelöst
hd1 ist vermutlich entstanden als das
universum erst 330 millionen jahre alt
war in menschenjahren umgerechnet war
das universum dort also nur ein bisschen
älter als zwei jahre durch beobachtung
des damals ausgesandten lichts hofft man
noch mehr aber die frühen jahre des
universums zu erfahren und das alter der
beiden galaxien genauer zu können ebenso
gibt es neue forschungsprojekte zu
gravitationswellen 2023 ist geplant den
nächsten rennen so nennt man die messe
durch läufe zu starten dabei hofft die
forschungsgruppe auf parallele daten von
james webb teleskop die die ergebnisse
zusätzlich bereichern würden sehr sparen
dazu werden wir auf jeden fall ein video
machen die suche nach wasser geht ebenso
weiter wasser wollen wir nicht nur auf
exoplaneten finden sondern es spielt
ebenso eine wichtige rolle bei der
planeten und atmosphären entstehung
damit können wir dann erforschen wie
leben auf der erde selbst möglich wurde
und wie die erde und die moleküle sich
entwickelt haben
falls ihr jetzt noch mehr wissen wollte
und die nächsten monate da nichts zu tun
habt dann haben wir euch ein paar links
in die video beschreibung gepackt da
könnt ihr euch in alle 286 millionen
einarbeiten da die messungen nun endlich
gestartet sind können wir uns also die
nächsten jahre auf jede menge james webb
neuigkeiten freuen und wir kommen dem
ziel die geheimnisse des universums zu
verstehen immer wieder einen schritt
näher sobald es etwas neues gibt dann
bekommt ihr natürlich hier auf doktor
watson die nötigen updates vergesst
nicht euch ein cooles james webb t shirt
zu bestellen denn nachdem die bestellung
und schließen gibt es vermutlich die
chance nie wieder bleibt wie man
neugierig direkt fürs zuschauen und bis
bald
[Musik]
ganz schön viel zeug dass da einfach so
herum schwirrt umschwirrt schmuggelt um
schwäbelt die erde ist
die schulter so
aber wir konnten euch nicht wie kommt's
nicht verstehen wir können euch nicht
widerstehen